well we're taking another plunge this
morning there's a local business hosting
a waffle eating contest that's right do
you have a big appetite
it's all to raise much needed funds for
the ccsd
police department's k-9 team alex yes
and it's happening on
international waffle day which is today
hector mejia he is live in the kitchen
he's been hard at work all morning
hi hector i can't wait to see what
you've come up with
i told you a little bit about that
earlier so we're getting ready for this
big waffle eating contest
i'm helping to make the waffles and i'm
really winning the price for the best
looking waffles this is
waffle number one barely standing up but
it's still delicious
and take a look at waffle number two it
is well done we forgot it was actually
in the oven
that's why it burned so uh joining us
live we have
contestant number one who promises to
eat
thousands of waffles this is sergeant
brian zink with ccsd
police department good morning are we
starting now or we sure are
go ahead and dig in no hey thank you for
having us today we're so excited about
this this is going to be a great
fundraiser for our k-9 team so we're
looking we're looking forward to it and
everyone's coming hungry so we're at
tiabe coffee and waffle which is right
off of
flamingo and maryland parkway officers
with the police department
they'll be out here starting at nine
o'clock this morning along with their
canines
as they raise money for for what tell us
i mean the bills get really expensive
yeah so this money is going to be for
the k9 team we're bringing on a couple
new dogs we're going to have oh thank
you
we're going to have uh some costs
associated with that you know we need to
make sure they have all the
state-of-the-art equipment that they
need and that our canine handlers get
the best training available so
all the funds raised here are going to
go directly to our canine team so it's
just
going to be a great event how many
canines do you guys currently have we
have four right now
we're bringing two on two more online so
we're gonna have a total of six
six joining ccsd and this is
tiffany tiffany is making a churro
waffle is that correct yes this is a
churro waffle it's one of my favorites
and we use you could build your own
waffle here and for today we're doing
buy one get one half off
can i help you make them all yeah
absolutely
you can build your own oh wait so my
ugly waffle transformed into this
beautiful
churro waffle look at this and i i'm
touching it because i'm gonna eat it
i'm gonna eat this one yeah that one's
all yours we're going to do it up it's
going to be
delicious so lastly before we run out of
time you guys also have a deal for those
uh
wanting to come down here and celebrate
international waffle day
you buy a waffle and you get the second
one half off
and you also get to build your own
waffle however you want
and then you feel amazing fantastic
tiffany thank you so we're going to keep
making some more waffles we'll talk with
sergeant brian zinke and tiffany in just
a few minutes for now reporting live
hector mejia and my beautiful waffles
back to you guys
yeah it's awesome well done
okay i guess there's he mistook the word
crispy
yeah yeah it's extra crispy i think alex
what do you think
the two of them together uh the woman
who owns the shop in heck they need
their own podcast or something
he's she's finishing his sentences
yeah and you know what that's sergeant
though looks he looks happy with hectors
with his cookies he looks hungry yeah he
hasn't looked in
like an hour there'll be another waffle
after that one so don't worry about it
that's right
good job and this heck and this waffle
is burned
yeah and this waffle looks better
one for me one for you two for me two
for you